see it now we're gonna see it later
Chuck I bet you $20 I'll buy the chip
won't even make a face without making a
face you almost not know where for
turning on me and tell them at Omega sci
fi till we die
there's nothing to me I already
accomplished it should be Megaman why I
have to wash my hands because I'm scared
I know well here you draw double teams
get filed get people see see here is
what we did somebody asked me what works
it says the defense of shack feet those
feet of those you know 28,000 points
[Laughter]
just better be underdog underdog told me
about you don't have a great
relationship with your best player
you're never going to win he did not
that's not true no just cause you say
some that's not true me it's not me
apparently never saw out I and what
happened to my where so it's not true
not true with the men on that team it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter the
story that's my I was a role player you
right but you know that's my point so
every time say huh what's your best
point don't know what you tell you
something stop baby we can't use that
champion no matter how much you scream
you'll answer that does not make you
right
there's your wrongness and you can
baby baby baby no play-doh play no
probably got a citizen's down period he
got to repair he got to repair nothing
you got stop baby I play you got baby
that's why you ain't win you got the I
didn't have the way I didn't have to
Wayne Wayne and Kobe Bryant carried me
up and down the court so why you know
how we talked about three finals if you
just because you grew gloomy you see
that will make you a great plan your
fight with a gaucho
he got a step up and a court you can
yell as much I got 3,000 feet I mean you
are a great player you will say I will
say you gonna stop I will say that there
is a stand that you take place team in
the East Boston Celtics taking on the
eight seed Brooklyn Nets and all I want
to talk about is big fella one a Scott
looks amazing thank you I noticed
something a little different let's just
get out the way America I had a bet
against one of my good friends d-wade
Milwaukee versus the Heat I said
Milwaukee was gonna win by 20 and a heat
one I said well what do you want me to
do pay you said nah you got to let your
hairline grow we want to see your
hairline looking like Kenny Smith oh I
just I've just lined it up for y'all so
you have to see where my hairline I'm
proud to do it and I'm keeping like this
all week all week this is your birthday
haircut I show up to my stylist he's
from Paris Texas his name is Leroy pata
rish rope Irish hookup to Ascot Wow my
own stylist all right Dee wage you win
and so listen you're not gonna hurt my
feelings sending your tweets B as soon
as you can yeah let's hear him we want
to see them all America hit us up NBA on
TNT he looked like a lot of people
[Laughter]
this is what's going on on Tuesday yeah
hey did we see mrs. C I knew the worst
idea in the world
you have not shown is bigger in the
hands of Shaquille O'Neal put the gun
down
here's one for the road this is brand
new suit - I'll be back and I thought
the funniest thing about dingus date was
the Anderson Cooper reaction to it a
couple of years ago I guess I was wrong
[Music]
[Laughter]
let me get you a father I get a gold
melon man
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the best Christmas ever
[Laughter]
as we close out 2016 here in studio J
American Express halftime report
Burnie Johnson chat Kenny and Charles if
it looks a little darker in his daugher
on this side of the set there's a reason
for that you've been complaining about
the light in your eyes
well I have not been for blender yeah
okay you know it's funny after say when
I'm a buster I'd be light up in there oh
man what it likes is too bright for you
yeah you know that yeah what are you
doing Jack I'm breaking the life there's
ten times early you don't see how black
you are you believe it just did smile
why would you break a light shot I felt
like I'm not breaking don't think we see
over there's your shirt but is it more
comfortable now for you I wipe my eye
with this thing every five minutes
well thank you so we if you have issues
here inside studio J we have an issue
not issue that's the gel want to be
funny upstairs I'm gonna break another
light after this I don't think that all
right you cranky tonight ma'am oh crank
you might have a caller was an
electrical fire in here man
you're trying to be funny but I am FM I
know you know you're great in trouble
alright cranky I'm coming for you oh
won't you come in agreement break one of
these TVs American Express vigilant no
other Lakers in the mask
there you go set him up cozies thumbs
those hands go we got next you think you
ready for this one whoa got the right
shot muscle blender you are laughs right
the Crippler against Shaq it's a proper
big offer versus the Crippler if he
starts getting crazy
what get him ready get it ready let's go
Shaq let's go sad let's go let's go
you good you're good I'm running ready
go
oh he's not even trying
[Applause]
all the way down like that your whole
body you here to slap you in the head
against long is that elbow stays on the
pad it's legal am i correct it's correct
as long as that elbow stays on the body
its insert it's the first time we gotta
let him have a little take a wicked
editing it here we go get my full time
get my boat right there all right you go
ahead Shaq you go you go that's where it
comes from
switch this one right there bring him
this way this way take that over ready
thank you so much man with a pleasure to
watch Crippler thanks appreciate you
my next one is 17th of May
great stuff Oh
[Laughter]
that that was good it's a wrap for
inside the NBA or additional penny
Charles Shaq Ernie Johnson bidding you a
good night from Atlanta we'll see you
away 30 nights